welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker binds together not just the
nine films of the Skywalker saga but
fragments from all across the Star Wars
universe including the animated series
the games popular legends stories and
longtime ire among the fanbase for
learning before I continue if you have
not yet seen the film the scene that
most expresses the rise of Skywalker's
appreciation of its past and the most
cryptic moment of the movie for me took
place during the final battle Rey in her
darkest moment here's a cacophony of
voices of Jedi past encouraging her to
keep fighting
there were cameos were a ton of famous
Jedi we know and love was some
interesting background on why each
character says what they say so let us
break it all down okay so as Rey watch
his resurrected Palpatine fry the
resistance fleet which sits lightening
her gaze glides beyond all the calamity
with the path of the Sith Lightning
branching off kind of like an electrical
signal through the neurons in a brain
deeper and deeper into space but also
deeper and deeper into Ray's mind
and finally Rey has broken free of the
battle and the atmosphere begs goal
scene only a clear look at the star
scape the same background that opens
every Star Wars opening crawl and she
chants be with me the Jedi prayer that
she repeated as her opening lines back
in the jungle floating with rocks
orbiting her doing her best impression
of a celestial body but unable to
connect with a Jedi but now her
consciousness has broken through to that
cosmos well the first voice we hear is a
male voice these are your final steps
Rey rise and take them this is a voice
of obi-wan Kenobi voice might Ewan
McGregor and his voice being first here
is a direct call back to you and Obi
Wan's voice being the last thing Rey
heard in her vision in the force awakens
when he whispered now next we hear three
voices say race name
hey hey ray the first is Hayden
Christensen is Anakin Skywalker and this
is a big deal for Christensen to come
back because he has largely been m.i.a
from the Star Wars universe since the
prequels now the second two are voices
from the animated series ashley eckstein
as ahsoka tano and freddie prinze jr. as
kanan jarrus and it's pretty cool for
the rise of Skywalker to involve them
like this past films have included like
droids and chips from the animated
series and the Mandalorian has given
voice actors cameos in the show but this
is the first time these performers have
been able to play their characters in a
live-action film and the inclusion of
ahsoka tano among these past two jedi is
interesting if you don't watch the
animated series
sokka is a badass Jedi character who
joins obi-wan and Anakin during the
Clone Wars but then it gets framed for
murder and she leaves the Jedi Order and
she was last seen in the final scene of
Star Wars rebels leaving for the Unknown
Regions after the Battle of Endor with
her fate beyond that left a mystery now
we may follow ahsoka and other
live-action stuff maybe she'll show up
in like season two of the Mandalorian or
in the obi-wan series but hearing her
voice here confirms that sometime over
the last three decades she did pass away
but she did become one with the Jedi
once more
kanan jarrus was the lead character of
rebels Jedi who survived order 66 and
lived under the name caleb dume but then
later in the series died in a
self-sacrifice and an explosion and then
i guess kind of manifests his will
through a pack of loathe wolves to help
his padawan Ezra Bridger and then we
again hear Anakin's voice saying bring
back the balance Rey as I did he's
referencing the prophecy that was so
critical to his life as a Jedi as a
child he was thought to be the prophecy
chosen one to bring balance to the force
but then as an adult he appeared to
overturn that philosophy but then
returned the Jedi Anakin Redemption did
in a sense bring balance back to the
force
I don't know if Annie wants to claim
this win I think we can give it to him
now the next voice we hear is the Jedi
Luminara Unduli who says the light find
the light ray Luminara was played by
Mary Oh Yaya and Attack of the Clones
and that her character was given
speaking lines in Clone Wars when she
was then voiced by olivia davao who
voices her hear her backstory like many
jedi is tragic but this is a real tragic
one because she dies under order 66 and
then after her execution the empire used
her remains to trick other Jedi Jedi
like kanan jarrus into thinking she
survived into luring them into a trap
and here saying find the light reflects
her name Luminara which is based on the
latin root word for light okay next we
hear a familiar voice
Yoda voiced as always by Frank Oz who
says alone never have you been and then
following Yoda is qui-gon Jen voiced by
Liam Neeson who says every Jedi who ever
lived lives in you the words lives in
you evoke wagons message to Anakin about
midi-chlorians
midi-chlorians
microscopic life-form that resides
within all living cells oh sorry didn't
mean to make you head but your screen
there but I like this reinterpretation
of the over codified biology of the past
into a more spiritual concept that these
life forms that live in the Jedi can
instead be the spirits of past Jedi next
Anakin's voice returns the force
surrounds you ray followed by a female
voice the Jedi Aayla Secura who says let
it guide you now a lo was the twilight
Jedi whom we saw gunned down an order 66
Revenge of the Sith to is played by Amy
Allen in the films but he or she's
voiced by Jennifer Hale who voiced her
in the Clone Wars animated series next
is my man mace windu samuel l.jackson
who says last time I trusted someone I
lost enough well he does say that but
here May says feel the force flowing
through you Ray and then Anakin's voice
returns again let it lift you and then
there is one more female voice Adi Galia
who says rise ray now Eddie was a Jedi
Master from the High Council performed
by Jane Clark in the live-action films
but voiced by Angelique Perrin in the
Clone Wars and in the scene in the Clone
Wars who's actually killed by Mol's
brother Savage Opress
now the echoes continue with qui-gon
saying please stand behind you ray and
then an odd voice ray this one again
from obi-wan but Alec Guinness his
version of the character in the original
films they were able to get an audio
clip of him saying the sound ray from a
line in the very first film come yeah my
little friend
don't be afraid and JJ Abrams took that
way and inserted it into rays forced
vision back in the force awakens and
then closing it out here Yoda says rise
in the force ray kanan jarrus says in
the hearts of a Jedi lies their strength
you and obi-wan says rise qui-gon says
rise and then it ends with the voice of
Luke Skywalker Rey the force will be
with you always
he's echoing the voice of obi-wan a to
Luke after guiding him in the trench run
on the Death Star in the very first bill
[Music]
with all the backing of Jedi past rey
climbs back up to her feet using the
twin blades of Leia and Luke to overcome
Palpatine and well yeah the rest is
history
just like the history we have seen drift
off into the Stars where these spirits
reside comment down below with your
favorite cameo and the rise of Skywalker
and be sure to check out all the other
videos we've been making on the film all
the Easter eggs and the deeper symbolism
that you might have missed what
Palpatine's planned was how and why Leia
came back and the deeper meaning of the
final scene follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at a box and subscribed into
rock stars for breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for joining me okay
[Music]